[Music]
breaking news this monday night
a deadly shooting rampage at a fourth of
july parade
oh my gosh
america's independence day marred by a
mass tragedy we started shooting again
and we ran behind the building
allegations of children in despair and
group homes in disrepair nobody cares
about them the claims kids were called
paychecks global news investigates
seizing control russia's new victory in
ukraine
and homewrecking
what shall i do now will i be left out
on the sidewalk opposition to the
impending demolition of egypt's historic
houseboats
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
with breaking news a fourth of july
parade in a chicago suburb has become
the scene of the latest mass shooting in
the u.s a gunman on a rooftop opened
fire on parade goers killing at least
six people dozens of others are in
hospital tonight robert e cremo the
third is in police custody he was
arrested after a brief pursuit right now
he's being called a person of interest
not a suspect mike armstrong now on how
a parade quickly turned into panic
it was a scene that changed in seconds
from a fun day for families out for a
parade
to moments some witnesses are calling
simply chaos
everyone from young children to seniors
running to safety running away from
gunfire
i thought that it was the navy that was
saluting the flag when the shooting was
over this man hid his son in a dumpster
and returned to the scene to look for
the rest of his family it was just
horrible i went back there was a few
people shot on the ground and there was
a little boy that was in somebody's one
of the
police officers arms and that's
that was the worst experience ever
according to the coroner five people
were killed at the scene a six died in
hospital all were adults the wounded
were taken to hospital dozens other
people at the scene were told to shelter
in place and wait for police to escort
them away
now the gunman disappeared as police
approached perched on a rooftop he
stopped shooting and escaped he left
behind a high-powered rifle recovered by
police i was very terrified i was i hit
with my daughter actually police are
speaking to witnesses and asking the
public for any surveillance video that
may contain clues they're also going
through social media in case the shooter
posted anything online i've been here 15
years every year i'm surprised
that it took this long this man says his
reaction to the mass shooting once he
stopped running wasn't surprised there
are too many shootings in the u.s for
that he says he just thought today
it was us mike armstrong global news
for a year global news in partnership
with aptn has been investigating the
state of the child welfare system in
ontario tonight we zero in on one of the
biggest names in privately run foster
care and group homes connor homes the
company by design makes money off kids
and care but it's the type of care these
children receive that caught our
attention allegations of kids going
hungry being mistreated and homes
falling apart all while the owners built
another company on the side luxury
vacation rentals for the rich carolyn
jarvis reports
on its website windswept offers vacation
properties
including waterfront retreats inns even
a private island it says you can fly
your float plane to
the properties are owned by the connor
family the patriarch bob connor stay
here and experience all the comforts of
home the website boasts
but this was home without comfort for
some of the kids living at the conner's
other properties
houses run by their other company connor
homes which operated for-profit foster
care and group homes for 46 years
and which still runs three group homes
in eastern ontario
these homes were in horrible shape
electricity not working water not
working that happened on a regular basis
former workers who asked that their
identities be concealed for fear of
reprisal say before the ceiling
collapsed in one of the homes they
repeatedly documented water damage in
daily logs but disrepair they say was
often left for weeks even months what
message does that send to the youth when
it's not worth fixing up their home that
nobody cares about them and that's
exactly what the youth would say there
are no parents here in group homes kids
and teens live together with rotating
staff a lot of people don't know what
happens
they need to see what's going on
ontario's ministry of children community
and social services had an idea of what
was going on
inspectors visited between 2019 and 2021
and interviewed a girl who said her
mattress was so uncomfortable she had to
pile several old blankets under her
sheets
inspectors also spoke with a boy who
lost his glasses at his last foster home
but says he was told by connor home
staff that he was not allowed to have a
new eye exam until december
nine months later they noted bed linens
were dirty and smelled of body odor and
there were mouse droppings in kitchen
drawers
and yet the province renewed connor's
group home licenses
this is happening and there's nothing
being done about it connor holmes which
declined an interview said it strives to
exceed the legislated minimum regulatory
standards adding its foster care license
was renewed by the ministry without any
conditions for the first 40 years
the ministry meanwhile says it's
increasing oversight and reviewing the
processes for inspections these kids in
these homes weren't a priority for every
child in its group homes connor holmes
receives a per diem payment using public
funds
as we uncovered 198 to two hundred and
thirteen dollars a day
some staff would say that they're a
paycheck what do you mean a staff would
call a youth a paycheck yeah i've heard
multiple staff say that to kids straight
to their face in its foster care
division money was also a motivator
connor homes would hire supervisors to
recruit foster parents and open new
homes paying them ten dollars a day for
every child placed in a home every young
person in care has a price tag we're
talking about companies doing business
through kids as commodities today the
conner family has amassed a real estate
portfolio owned personally and through
their companies worth over 10 million
dollars according to global news's
calculations meanwhile there were
complaints to the province as recently
as 2020 that kids were going hungry
carolyn jarvis global news
and we continue our investigation into
connor homes tomorrow night when we hear
firsthand from a young man who lived
there and says those facilities are no
place to raise a child
first nations children and families
harmed by chronic underfunding of the
child welfare system will be officially
compensated the federal government says
it has signed a 20 billion agreement
half of the money it plans to use to
reform the system the news comes as the
assembly of first nations prepares for
its annual meeting it begins tomorrow in
vancouver under a cloud of uncertainty
following allegations of bullying and
harassment the organization's national
chief has now been removed from the
agenda for opening day nitu garcia
reports
fix anything that needs to be fixed it's
a great opportunity ralph leon is among
hundreds of chiefs elders youth and
representatives from across the country
meeting in vancouver for what is
expected to be a heated week at the
assembly of first nations annual general
assembly nobody has that right to
ban our national chief from her meeting
the afn reversed an earlier statement
that national chief roseanne archibald
would be barred from attending this
week's meetings after archibald made an
urgent court appearance in ontario last
week to ensure she can legally attend
but the judge rejected her bid to
overturn her suspension i stand behind a
national chief and what she needs to do
cook pee or chief judy wilson says
archibald is dealing with issues that
have compounded over years relating to
the afn's governance foundation policies
and procedures there were issues that
needed to be addressed then that we were
told were addressed but unfortunately
they're not addressed because now
they're escalated
to the forefront of this aga wilson
supports calls for a forensic audit
spanning the last eight years after
archibald alleged she was being
persecuted for trying to investigate
corruption within the assembly i think
as chiefs across canada we're just
looking for the facts and information i
don't want to buy into the drama he said
she said as they gathered for private
meetings monday archibald tweeted the
regional chiefs continue to try and
silence me my call for transparency
accountability and truth they have
erased the national chief from the
agenda this is a chiefs in assembly
meeting not an afn exec meeting
forensic audit now if the national chief
is forced out
in some through some you know
legal process
that will cause even more dissension and
difficulty
in the organization so
we will be watching the afn meeting with
more attention than we have in recent
years we can't lose focus on why we're
here especially amid a pivotal point in
canadian history with a reconciliation
focused papal visit to canada just a few
weeks away many here say now is a
critical time to bridge these divides
nitu garcia global news vancouver
ahead of his trip to canada later this
month pope francis is addressing rumors
about his health in a rare interview the
head of the catholic church dropped some
hints about his future at the vatican
and weighed in on world news eric
sorensen reports
the vatican rumor mill has been churning
the pope looks frail there are whispers
of cancer and an upcoming visit to the
same city pope benedict went to before
he resigned all led some to believe the
pope is preparing to step down
so francis sat down for a long interview
with reuters to quell the gossip and get
some things off his chest
first there is no cancer i mean
at least he says the doctors haven't
told me he described the leg fracture
that has kept him from making a trip to
africa but says he'll be ready to travel
soon
i will do the trip to canada because the
doctor told me with 20 more days you
will recover
in fact his visit here is now just 20
days away it will begin with a gesture
of reconciliation when he arrives in
edmonton
in april at the vatican the pope
apologized for the abuses committed by
members of the catholic church against
indigenous children who were forced to
attend residential schools demonstrating
his vigor he said he wants to follow
that with trips to russia and ukraine to
the
after i come back from canada i may go
to ukraine
and if russia's president gives me a
tiny window he would go to moscow to
serve the cause of peace
the pope also took up the controversial
u.s supreme court decision bringing new
restrictions on abortions
unlike many american protesters francis
respects the decision and condemns
abortion
is it right he asked to take a human
life to resolve a problem
it is a moral question he said and while
francis is not planning to resign soon
he did say he's prepared to do what pope
benedict was the first to do in a
thousand years to step down before he
dies
for the moment no but the time will come
when i see that i can't do it and i will
follow the great example of benedict
and when might that be
we don't know he says
god will say
eric sorensen global news toronto
nothing but luggage and lineups coming
up the never-ending nightmare at
canada's busiest airports
to the chaos at canadian airports now
where travelers are fed up with last
minute flight cancellations lengthy
delays and long lines during one of the
busiest times on the calendar tonight
abigail beeman looks at the growing
backlogs and what it could mean for your
summer getaway
[Music]
no one seems to be immune from the lost
luggage nightmare the arkells landed in
saskatoon but their gear flew somewhere
else so they had to borrow for their
saturday concert
[Music]
after learning a new song friday in
surrey bc because their opening acts
band's flight was canceled they canceled
all my flights
just like that
i mean i paid thousands
the center of chaos still toronto's
pearson airport i've been here since
eight o'clock last night i haven't slept
i went to a hotel the hotel tells me
that the air canada gaming doesn't work
it's been a lot busier than i thought
we're just flying to montreal and the
line has been crazy it wasn't clearly
online what we had to do when we arrived
here
so they didn't accept our coveters on
our app were irish
so
they wanted it all on paper form
so that was a bit of a hassle
lost luggage delayed luggage it's a
problem in many places this is the scene
here in ottawa in this pile i see car
seats mobility devices there's a bag
with a crew tag here right in front of
me some people having to wait days to be
reunited with their bags i think i had
three or four cancellations and i slept
overnight in toronto at the airport
monica lung arrived in ottawa wednesday
it was supposed to be tuesday she's now
getting this bag five days later it's
annoying but i mean like i don't blame
air canada exactly it's like all the
airlines at the same time this aviation
expert blames airlines the government
and airports for a migraine inducing
situation he calls somewhat predictable
a lot of people left the industry pilots
retired the flight attendants went on to
more lucrative jobs less demanding jobs
at least and so they had a shortage of
people on the airlines as well as the
airports something most experts agree on
things aren't expected to improve during
this busy season it will only get worse
before it gets better because you know
summer has just started we had our first
long weekend of the summer we have tons
of pent up demand and one perhaps
obvious tip if you don't absolutely need
to check a bag don't
abigail beeman global news ottawa
sydney swamped ahead the
life-threatening emergency in
australia's largest city
ukrainian soldiers have now pulled out
of the strategic city of lysichans
russian forces move one step closer to
capturing the entire donbass region
russia is calling those territorial
gains an important victory but as
redmond shannon reports they represent a
major come down from vladimir putin's
initial goals for the invasion
military protection in serene lugano
switzerland it's a pleasure to have you
here for a conference focused on
rebuilding ukraine the kremlin's goal is
the military
political
and economic destruction of ukraine
ukraine's prime minister says the full
long-term recovery bill may be close to
one trillion dollars this support
encourages us for faster win it gave us
hope to have peaceful times and
reconstruct and recover my country
dennis smihal wants countries to follow
canada's plan to use frozen russian
assets to pay for some of that
the funds may one day be used here
luhansk region now completely under
russian control after ukrainian troops
withdrew from the city of lissy chansk
the regional governor says his forces
could have held out for two or three
more weeks but would have ended up dying
for nothing luhansk is one of two
regions that make up the donbass in
ukraine's east the other is donetsk
russian-backed forces have controlled
parts of both since 2014 and russia
still only controls about half of
donetsk
vladimir putin described the advance as
a liberation but four months into the
invasion these are scaled-back victories
compared to russia's initial plans every
one of these big battles at leasty
chance sevilla donetsk mariupol they are
long grinding battles and the russians
are paying dearly for what they take
analysts believe the arrival of more
advanced western weapons could soon give
ukraine the upper hand as battles move
into donetsk
ukraine recently received these u.s
highmars rocket systems they need them
in much higher numbers if it's going to
make the kind of difference that uh
ukraine really needs for an outright
military victory and the ukrainians have
said as much ukraine's other problem
could be the manpower behind those
weapons as it reportedly deals with
ongoing heavy losses on the battlefront
redmond shannon global news london
the bodies of 12 mariners have been
recovered after a chinese research
vessel broke in two and sank during a
powerful storm the vessel with its crew
of 30 was moored at what was supposed to
be a safe anchorage to wait out tropical
storm chaba but the ship's anchor chain
snapped and the vessel was pummeled by
the storm four of its crew were rescued
but hopes of finding anyone else alive
are being described as very slim
at least seven people are dead and at
least another 13 missing in the italian
alps after a large chunk of a glacier
broke loose causing a landslide video
captured the avalanche sending ice snow
and rock onto a trail popular with
hikers and climbers eight people are in
hospital and rescue crews continue to
search for those unaccounted for italy
has been experiencing an early summer
heat wave and decades of rising
temperatures have caused the marmalade
glacier to shrink
30 thousand people have been told to
abandon their homes as life-threatening
flash floods are rising around
australia's largest city
dams are overflowing and three major
rivers have burst their banks around
sydney's outer suburbs the same area was
hit by flooding in march killing 20
people australia's emergency management
minister says there's a good chance this
one will be worse with some areas having
received more than a meter and a half of
rain in the last 24 hours
hope floats next why residents of
cairo's historic houseboats are praying
for a miracle on the nile
egypt sprawling capital cairo is
undergoing a major transformation the
jewel of the nile is one of the world's
biggest tourist attractions and is
trying to keep up with the rapid
modernization of its neighbors building
shiny new high-rises bridges and roads
but as mike delay explains as cairo
builds for the future a part of the
city's rich history is being discarded
progress isn't always pretty at times it
can be downright cruel
save for a brief period after getting
married nicholas helmy has spent all of
her 87 years living on the nile in the
heart of cairo egypt
my entire life has been in a houseboat
she says i was born in a houseboat this
is my entire life i cannot leave it
but last month the government declared
the remaining houseboats moored on the
nile unsafe and unlicensed and ordered
them demolished the river nile the
shores are lined with thousands of
houseboats there was a time when cairo's
houseboats hosted egypt's political and
cultural elite governments it's been
said have been formed on these very
boats but over the years their numbers
dwindled leaving only the 32 that are
now being removed despite some
last-ditch attempts to save them we've
been here for 10 years this is our home
and
we feel like we have no choice but to
just stay where we are and see what
happens
what's happening is cairo is in the
midst of a transformation as the
government aims to modernize and
monetize its most desirable addresses
soon this stretch of the nile will be
lined with floating cafes and
restaurants while this former resident
looks for a new place to live
we collected our possessions our stories
our history our hearts our memories and
our feelings he says and place them into
boxes
will progress transform cairo into a
more modern city perhaps but by cutting
ties to its romantic history cairo will
lose something as well
mike trolley global news
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is the nicola
valley in merit british columbia we love
to see your canada please email yours to
viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
i'll see you again tomorrow night good
night
[Music]
you